Alemania no solo es un país muy rico, también
es un país famoso por funcionar como un reloj
suizo y fabricar cosas de mucha calidad. [Esa
al menos es la fama, si alemán, es bueno.]
El caso es que durante las últimas
décadas Alemania experimentó uno de
los milagros económicos más importantes de toda
la historia. Os hemos hablado ya de ello tanto
aquí en VisualPolitik como en nuestro canal
hermano VisualEconomik. Hoy el país germano
es sinónimo de alta productividad, empresas muy
prósperas y unos trabajadores muy cualificados.
Sin embargo, tiene un problema, un problema
potencialmente muy grave y del que todavía
no os hemos hablado: su incapacidad para
atraer mano de obra cualificada. ¿Alguna
vez te has planteado irte a trabajar Alemania?
Seguro que muchos de vosotros lo habéis hecho,
pero seguro también que sois muchos menos
que los que habéis pensado en Reino Unido,
Países Bajos, Canadá, Australia
o, no digamos ya, Estados Unidos.
Pese a ser un país muy rico, con
muchos empleos y aparentemente la
oportunidad de construir grandes
carreras profesionales, Alemania
no parece ser un sitio nada atractivo
para los trabajadores más cualificados.
“Rankea” mucho peor que el resto de sus países
comparables. No llega al extremo
de Japón… Pero es una anomalía.
Una anomalía que, queridos amigos,
amigas, siempre es un problema,
pero que lo es aún mucho más cuando tu población
en edad de trabajar se está reduciendo.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Por qué demonios Alemania
resulta un destino tan poco atractivo para
los extranjeros más cualificados? ¿Qué puede
suponer esto para la que tradicionalmente ha sido
considerada la locomotora de Europa? ¿Qué está
haciendo el gobierno para remediar esta situación?
Pues bien, en este vídeo os vamos a responder
a todas estas preguntas. Y quien sabe,
quizás al final te plantes mudarte
al país germano… O tal vez no.
Arranquemos.
Amigos y amigas, Alemania es un país
top 10. Y con ello nos referimos a que
casi está entre los 10 mejores países
cuando miramos prácticamente cualquier
índice de bienestar y desarrollo: PIB
per cápita, niveles de escolaridad,
grados de productividad, acceso a
servicios básicos, etc., etcétera.
Pero sus fábricas de última generación,
sus modernas aulas educativas y su más que
envidiable inversión anual en desarrollo
tecno-industrial no tendrían sentido si
no existieran profesores, ingenieros,
médicos, operarios y profesionales que pongan
en marcha todo este inmenso aparato productivo.
Y el problema… El problema lo podemos
empezar a ver perfectamente en esta gráfica:
(Según cifras oficiales de la ONU, a partir
de este 2023 la población alemana empezará a
contraerse. De una población total de cerca
de 83 millones de personas en la actualidad,
la previsión a punta a que se perfore el piso de
los 80 millones en 2047 y el de los
70 para la última década del siglo.
No es una contracción tan salvaje como la
que se espera se produzca en países como
Japón o Corea del Sur, pero, aun así,
es relevante desde el punto de vista
económico. Estos datos básicamente
significan no solo menos población,
también población envejecida y, por tanto,
mucha menos mano de obra disponible.)
Lógicamente, todo esto responde a cambios en
los patrones de natalidad, pero hay algo que
también puede incrementar el impacto económico de
este declive: la falta de retención del talento.
Sí, Alemania recibe mucha inmigración,
eso seguro, seguro, que todos lo habéis
escuchado. Sin embargo, en esta historia hay
un problema: cada vez que un trabajador alemán
altamente cualificado se jubila, no es fácil
sustituirle, porque -como veremos- en Alemania
no sobra la inmigración, pero sobre todo lo
que no sobra es la inmigración cualificada.
Y la pregunta, por tanto, es: ¿Quién puede
decirle que No al gigante alemán? ¿Por qué
se prefieren otros destinos? Estas son las
preguntas cuya respuesta tenemos que averiguar.
Para hacerlo, lo primero, lo primero de todo tiene
que ser entender cómo hemos llegado hasta aquí.
(T1. LAS PRIMERAS CAMPANADAS DEMOGRÁFICAS)
No es un caso aislado, la mayor parte de
los países desarrollados - y también otros
no tan desarrollados como China
o Rusia - están experimentando un
acelerado proceso de envejecimiento demográfico.
Y, ojo, porque este proceso no solo
reduce la mano de obra disponible,
también eleva considerablemente el gasto público:
Pensadlo bien, pensiones, sanidad, dependencia…
El caso es que Alemania entendió el problema,
¿Y sabéis qué? Comenzó a hacer sus deberes muy
pronto, ni más ni menos que hace ya medio siglo.
(En la década de los 70 se produjo un punto de
inflexión en Alemania, su población nativa comenzó
a reducirse. Esto es, el país entró en una fase de
crecimiento vegetativo negativo. Como podéis ver a
partir de los años 70 el número de defunciones
ha superado cada año el número de nacimientos.
Para compensarlo, Alemania comenzó a impulsar
la inmigración. Como podéis ver, el número
de inmigrantes que llega cada año es por regla
general mayor que la pérdida nativa de habitantes.
Esto le ha permitido al país mantener su
crecimiento demográfico durante todos estos años.)
Todo depende de la llegada de nuevos inmigrantes.
Y si os fijáis en el gráfico veréis como
a principios del siglo XXI sonó la primera
alarma: la llegada de inmigrantes se desplomó.
A comienzos del siglo XXI, casi
toda Europa crecía y lo hacía más
que Alemania. El país germano no era ni
mucho menos la única flor en un jardín
de prosperidad cada vez más amplio… Y
eso, lógicamente, tuvo consecuencias.
La competencia frenó la llegada de nueva
mano de obra a las industrias germanas.
La pregunta es, ¿Qué es lo que hicieron?
Pues lo cierto es que los alemanes se lo tomaron
muy pero que muy en serio. El gobierno sabía
perfectamente lo importante que era atraer el
talento joven y mantener la expansión demográfica
para evitar que tanto la economía como la
propia Seguridad Social entraran en crisis.
Y para lograrlo, además de promover
activamente la inmigración,
también hicieron cosas como esta, fijaos.
N1(1 de enero de 2005: Entra en vigor la primera
ley de inmigración alemana. A partir del próximo
año, los nuevos inmigrantes tendrán derecho
a participar en clases de alemán financiadas
por el estado y recibir una introducción al
sistema judicial, la cultura y la historia
del país. El Gobierno ha destinado más
de 200 millones de euros a este plan. DW)
Las medidas funcionaron, y
el número neto de inmigrantes que cada año llegaba
al país prácticamente se triplicó. De 73.000 en
2004 se pasó 212.000 en 2008. Y no solo eso, para
el 2016, se tocó uno de los techos históricos en
materia de población inmigrante: 432.000 personas
no alemanas se trasladaron a vivir a este país.
Claro que, lógicamente, Alemania es parte
de la Unión Europea. ¿Y qué significa eso?
Pues que el país está sujeto a la libre
movilidad de personas y trabajadores.
Cualquiera de los miembros comunitarios puede
convertirse en un país rival por la mano de
obra. Una competencia creciente que Alemania no
parecer haber sido capaz de gestionar muy bien.
(T2. “DANKE” PERO NO)
A partir del año 2013 la llegada de inmigrantes
a Alemania comenzó a desacelerarse de nuevo.
Y lo que es aún peor, según los informes de
la OCDE el país era cada vez menos atractivo
para la llegada de profesionales. Porque,
y esto es importante, no todas las personas
son iguales. Lógicamente, desde el punto de
vista económico, la cualificación cuenta.
Y eso es lo que explica que la OCDE
hiciera esta advertencia. Fijaos.
C1(4 de febrero de 2013: Migración laboral:
Alemania está abierta a los graduados,
pero la inmigración es difícil para los
trabajadores medianamente cualificados.)
Y, ¿por qué decía esto la OCDE? Pues
básicamente por esto. Atentos a los datos.
C2(“Alemania es uno de los países de la OCDE
con las barreras más bajas a la inmigración
para trabajadores altamente cualificados. Sin
embargo, el número de trabajadores inmigrantes
de fuera de la UE y del Área Europea de Libre
Comercio (AELC) que recibe es de 25.000 al año,
alrededor del 0,02% de la población
(…) La tasa de trabajadores inmigrantes
cualificados que reciben Australia,
Dinamarca, Canadá y el Reino Unido es
de cinco a diez veces mayor”. Informe de la
OCDE sobre el mercado laboral alemán. 2013)
Es decir, supuestamente emigrar a Alemania
era relativamente fácil, pero, aun así,
los trabajadores cualificados preferían - y aún
prefieren - otros destinos. Ya sea por el idioma,
por las normas o por el estilo de vida, el
caso es que Alemania no es un destino popular.
Claro que esa no es toda la historia. Una
encuesta realizada por el International
Institute for Management Development con sede en
Suiza, descubrió que la percepción que tenían los
empresarios alemanes sobre la facilidad para
contratar talento internacional era más bien
pobre. Es decir, que el informe de la OCDE
no reflejaba fielmente toda la realidad.
Al parecer, los trámites burocráticos
venían siendo un problema desde hace
ya una década. En cierta forma, la
legislación para atraer inmigración
cualificada que databa del año
2005 estaba quedándose obsoleta
en comparación con los incentivos que
ponían sobre la mesa los países vecinos.
Por eso, entre los años 2018 y el 2020, el
parlamento alemán comenzó a realizar varios
cambios en la Ley. Cambios para dar mayor
facilidad a los profesionales de fuera de
la Unión Europea. Por ejemplo, se facilitaba
que los inmigrantes llegaran sin un contrato.
Sin embargo, justo entonces, la pandemia
cambio por completo el panorama.
(La propia Agencia Federal del Trabajo viene
realizando desde el año 2013 un seguimiento
de lo que las autoridades denominan como
profesiones “cuello de botella”. Esto es,
áreas del mercado de trabajo dónde las ofertas
laborales no consiguen cubrirse con los
trabajadores disponibles. En 2020 esta situación
se enfrió, pero a partir de entonces la tendencia
ha regresado. Cada vez más campos de la economía
alemana son incapaces de lograr los trabajadores
cualificados que necesitan. De hecho, se espera
que en 2023 este indicador bata récords.)
La reactivación económica tras la pandemia junto
al creciente envejecimiento demográfico están
llevando al mercado laboral alemán
a un contexto cada vez más crítico:
Mientras que la demanda de trabajadores no
deja de crecer, el número de inmigrantes que
llega cada año se ha reducido. Y no digamos
ya el número de los inmigrantes cualificados.
Para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
estamos hablando, según las estimaciones
del Instituto Económico Alemán de Colonia,
a mediados del 2022 había ya 1,5 millones de
vacantes en este país. Un dato que se espera
crezca con fuerza durante los próximos años.
La situación ha llegado a tal punto que
algunas áreas comerciales han tenido que
empezar a prestar sus servicios de forma reducida.
Y esto es, de hecho, lo que
explica noticias como esta:
N3(25 de junio de 2022: Alemania recurrirá
a trabajadores extranjeros temporales
para paliar la escasez de personal en los
aeropuertos alemanes. Las fotos de viajeros
haciendo largas colas en los controles
de seguridad del aeropuerto de Düsseldorf
a principios de esta semana mostraron
la magnitud de la escasez. Reuters)
Es decir, la economía alemana necesita
urgentemente mano de obra de todo tipo.
Según cálculos del Instituto de
Investigac ión sobre el Mercado
de Trabajo y el Empleo de Alemania, hace
falta que cada año lleguen un mínimo de
400 mil personas para mantener
estable la población activa.
Eso ya es un problema. Pero, amigos, lo de
la mano de obra cualificada libre… Eso ya
es casi una especie en peligro de extinción
en este país. Según una encuesta realizada
en diciembre de 2022, 7 de cada 10 empresas
están faltas de mano de obra especializada.
Y no solo eso, es que para colmo Alemania
se enfrenta ahora a otro problema:
Ya no es que no lleguen pocos trabajadores
cualificados, es que muchos de lo que había
se están marchando. Es decir, que el país está
sufriendo una fuga de cerebros. Y eso, eso es
algo que pone en peligro la formidable industria
que alimenta el mayor motor económico de Europa.
Pero… Volvamos a la pregunta
que nos hacíamos al principio:
¿Cómo demonios es posible que no haya casi
profesionales que quieran vivir y trabajar
en uno de los países más desarrollados
del mundo? ¿Dónde está el problema?
Pues… ¡Atentos!
(T3. LOS TRES PILARES DE LA RE-FUGA DE TALENTOS)
Si tratamos de ir directamente al centro
del asunto, podríamos decir que Alemania
se enfrenta a 3 grandes problemas. Cada
uno de ellos concatenado con el resto.
Por ejemplo, en primer lugar… ¡No
se puede pretender que el stock
de capital humano procedente de Europa sea eterno!
(Según las cifras oficiales, Serbia ha perdido el
9% de sus habitantes en las últimas tres décadas,
Macedonia del Norte el 10%, Bosnia y
Herzegovina el 24% y Albania el 37%. Y
algo muy parecido podríamos decir con Polonia
o las repúblicas bálticas, entre otros. Todos
estos países han perdido gran parte de sus
jóvenes mejor formados y más cualificados.
Y, claro, Europa es un continente muy envejecido,
así que la cantidad de trabajadores
cualificados disponibles para ser
captados por las empresas alemanas es
limitada. La cantera ya no da más de sí.)
En esta línea, muchos expertos estiman que
el “efecto inicial” de las ampliaciones de la
Unión Europea ya se ha terminado. Quizás Ucrania
fuese la única excepción, pero este país también
ha sufrido ya un enorme éxodo de trabajadores
cualificados, sobre todo, lógicamente, jóvenes.
Por eso, muchos analistas apuntan
a que la búsqueda de talento tiene
que mirar más allá de las fronteras continentales.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Esto es exactamente lo que hizo
que la reforma en 2020 de la Ley de Inmigración
Cualificada introdujera más facilidades para
los inmigrantes cualificados de terceros países.
Por ejemplo, se dejó de exigir títulos
universitarios para aceptar también
la formación profesional como prueba de
cualificación. Una petición que llevaban
tiempo haciendo los empresarios alemanes.
¿Por qué? Pues fijaos en este gráfico.
Por supuesto, esa no fue la única medida. También
se redujeron algunos trámites administrativos,
sin embargo, no se logró solventar el
principal escollo. Que no es otro que este.
(El sistema burocrático de inmigración alemán es
sumamente complejo: en el proceso intervienen al
menos 7 ministerios, sin tener en cuenta
las agencias gubernamentales de segundo
orden y los gobiernos locales. Solo por poner
un ejemplo, en la aprobación de un profesional
cualificado, intervienen:
el Ministerio Federal de
Asuntos Económicos y Acción Climática,
el Ministerio de Trabajo y Asuntos Sociales,
el Ministerio de Educación e Investigación,
el Ministerio de Alimentación y Agricultura,
el Ministerio de Salud,
el Ministerio del Interior y Comunidad
y el Ministerio de Cooperación
Económica y Desarrollo. ¡Casi nada!)
Esto obviamente plantea un importante desincentivo
para las empresas alemanas. En 2022,
solo el 17% de las empresas encuestadas
por la Fundación Bertels-mann contrató
trabajadores cualificados en el extranjero.
Y si bien las grandes empresas pueden contratar
consultoras y despachos jurídicos para acelerar
el proceso, las pymes se enfrentan a
una barrera prácticamente infranqueable.
Es decir, en cierta forma, la ampliación
de la elegibilidad de 2020 fue en la
dirección correcta para empezar a seducir a
profesionales de fuera de la Unión Europea,
sin embargo, no se preparó a
la burocracia para tal desafío:
La movilidad dentro del bloque común es
mucho más sencilla, pero al empezar a
incorporar a profesionales de otras regiones, la
documentación y los requisitos se multiplican.
Es infinitamente más difícil y costoso
incorporar a un trabajador tailandés o uruguayo
que uno polaco. Este es el segundo problema.
Y por último, el tercer gran escollo tiene
que ver con un factor mucho más complejo:
el cultural… Aunque solo sea por el idioma
En agosto de 2022, la Agencia Federal de
Empleo alemana puso su atención en
este asunto. ¿Y sabéis qué encontró?
Que la mayoría de trabajadores que llegan
a Alemania sin saber alemán no se molestan
siquiera en intentar aprenderlo. ¿Por qué?
Pues porque están pensando en marcharse.
Los problemas de integración idiomática,
los problemas para obtener la residencia
permanente, el precio de la vivienda,
el coste de la vida y los impuestos,
los problemas para reunificar a la familia
en el país o el choque con la cultura local
son los argumentos más frecuentes que dan los
trabajadores cualificados que deciden marcharse
de Alemania. Es algo de lo que en cierta
forma ya os hemos hablado en VisualEconomik.
Para colmo, la legislación migratoria
choca con un nuevo tipo de trabajo al
que prácticamente no tiene
en cuenta: los freelancers.
Pues bien, estos 3 problemas parecen
explicar por qué Alemania no es un
país tan atractivo como aparentemente debería ser.
La pregunta es, ¿Hay alguna salida? ¿Qué
están haciendo los políticos alemanes?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(T4. RETOMANDO EL “JOB APPEAL”)
Las estimaciones del Ministerio de Trabajo alemán
plantean que si para 2026 esta situación no se
revierte, más de 200.000 puestos hoy ocupados
quedarán vacantes. Una situación que podría
impactar muy negativamente en las empresas, la
productividad y el crecimiento económico del país.
Por eso, en octubre del 2022 el tema pasó
a ser prioritario en la agenda pública:
N4(22 de octubre de 2022: Cómo Alemania planea
atraer extranjeros cualificados. Las reformas
incluyen la introducción de la llamada "tarjeta
de oportunidad" que dará derecho a las personas
a buscar trabajo en Alemania siguiendo un sistema
de puntos basado en las habilidades lingüísticas,
la experiencia profesional y la conexión con
Alemania, entre otros criterios. IndiaTimes)
Y finalmente el pasado 29 de marzo la Ley de
Inmigración Cualificada fue reformada nuevamente,
N5(29 de marzo de 2023: Los
extranjeros con experiencia
laboral adecuada y formación en su país
de origen podrán trabajar en Alemania,
incluso si esos títulos profesionales no
están reconocidos en Alemania. Además,
se les permitirá trabajar hasta 20 horas a la
semana mientras buscan empleo a largo plazo.
Por último, será posible que las personas en
posesión de títulos académicos o certificados
profesionales permanezcan en Alemania
hasta un año mientras buscan empleo. DW)
¿Funcionará está nueva reforma? Solo el
tiempo podrá decirlo. La pregunta ahora es:
¿Te plantearías vivir en Alemania? ¿Te
gustaría hacerlo? ¿De qué forma crees
que este país puede impulsar la llegada
de nuevo talento? Déjanos tu respuesta en
los comentarios y abramos debate. Y ahora
si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.